at some point you tried to become a
writer on saturday night live a
performer yeah performer writer yeah and
you had your big meeting with lorne
michaels yeah yeah and you walk in the
office and you sit down and he has candy
on his desk yeah
and you swear
that you think you didn't get that
saturday night live job because you ate
the candy off his desk i was a little
high
you were she showed up high for the
meeting with lauren a little bit just a
little little pot why would you do that
that's the that wasn't that a big deal
to you to make it onto saturday night
live it was it was and yet just show up
high because you got to have your wits
about you to to talk to lauren now yeah
but i also like i you know i believed in
i romanticized the the mythology of
saturday night live i felt like i just
have a little bit i wasn't wasted i
didn't go and i and it was weird because
when i had that meeting i walked out
tracy morgan was waiting to go in and
why do you think he didn't get it
because lauren keeps a jar of candy well
you know obviously you know i read into
like i thought it was some sort of test
i'm sitting there with lauren michaels
and he's like looking at me in the eyes
weird right to the point where higgins
you know the the head writer you know he
was lauren's just looking at me right
and higgins goes lauren and he's like
you can tell a lot from looking in
someone's eyes
so now i'm sitting there like trying to
exude starness you know like from my eye
you know he just if i was high on pod i
would be paranoid if somebody's right
that's i think that's where the candy
theory came in yeah who the hell knows
right so you saw the candy you grabbed a
piece of candy i took a jolly rancher
and i put it in my mouth and i swear my
memory higgins and lauren looked at each
other like that's it
took the jolly round
that's it
he didn't pass the test do you end up
watching saturday night live that season
and going let me see who got hired let
me
i didn't i heard i was brought in later
some guy you know writer guy who had
written an article on alternative comedy
said you know i heard that they uh they
were just using you to get norm to to
re-up oh right it was a political it was
like a threat thing
you